the results is what matters what matters  is not your feelings what matters is the  results at the end of the day and so if  the results are a certain percentage of  women 80 are leaving marriages your  feelings don't come into the situation  because what's happening is because  everyone's going to have different  feelings right this woman said it was  because of that reason that woman said  it because of that reason it was because  of this but at the end of the day the  result is it's 80 of women leaving  marriage  and at the end of the day it's the kids  who suffer because you're putting your  feelings above the kids and this is I'm  taking out exceptions like abuse outside  outside of abuse you're putting your  your feelings above the children